what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a fresh and fit
podcast clip before i begin do not
forget to subscribe to the channel as
you guys know
i'm trying to hit 20 000 subscribers and
each and every one of you
helps while you're at it do not forget
to hit ring the notification bell that
way you're going to be notified for
my daily videos okay
and this was another clip submitted to
me on
want to trigger a girl easily drop this
line
let's see if i get training you know the
other day whatever
and we came to like a discovery yeah we
get the hundreds of girls over a period
of time
and what was that discovery with clubs
going oh well okay we're going to reveal
it we're going to tell the truth
okay 90 of the time when girls go to the
club is to get attention and validation
from men
it's not even really for like yeah
that's not i would say a club is
different than a bar but a club
an actual club yeah
that's exactly what i'm trying to say
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying they go out to turn up with their
girls when they could have done that at
the house but why are they doing it at
the nightclub they're doing it because
whether they have a boyfriend or not
they enjoy the attention from other men
they enjoy the fact that they can
leverage sex against men they enjoy that
men desire them
they enjoy the free drinks they enjoy
their attention they enjoy the pictures
an actual nightclub yeah i think
there's some situations where you might
go to a bar and they're like a dinner
with friends you know um i could see
that but an actual club where people are
like dancing and [ __ ] yeah
any anyone with half a half you can do
all that stuff
at your house
that's a plus not a must that's
if a guy comes up and says hey what's up
how you doing and everything like that
that's a plus
that's not marcos
that's what i gotta say and if it's four
years for you if it's not you ain't
gonna fit it
i mean nowadays it ain't about the duels
nowadays some girls are in
competition with other women that part i
mean
you can be enjoying yourself and a woman
can see you looking good or if you got
fat ass nice titties nice hair nice
dress and
other women i hate on you some women are
in competition with other women just
like some [ __ ] are just in competition
with other people he got a nice shame i
got to go with or
that's why people get robbed nowadays
there are some people looking at you
while you live in your damn life so
nowadays people are in competition with
the same
type of person that's just like them
when you just do you can do the same
[ __ ] that i'm doing and be where i'm at
that's all that's uh and i say that it
makes sense no no i'll let them finish
then i'll make and then i'll make my
last point
go ahead really quickly it makes sense
for both because
i think i don't remember who said it but
someone said that if
like girls go out oh you did you said
they go out there and they
they appreciate it like they know they
look good they appreciate the comments
they appreciate the
you coming up to them and all that they
like the attention yeah we like it
yeah just the same as one of those
pretty boys that they have all these
followers and everything on
on instagram tick tock whatever social
media or they know for a fact without
that they look good they know it they
look in the mirror and they're like
i know i look good so when they go out
and you look at them
they give you the same vibe that a
female does when she knows she look good
she's not going to give you that time of
day if you're not the one she wants
because she's going to be like yeah
thank you
i know okay okay but they're missing the
point all they're saying is
that's the reason you go to clubs is to
talk to like
guys versus girls um that sounds great
on paper but let's be real here
i actually still approached the guy
while i was in a relationship just to
get to get let him know that he had
dropped something but like i still
you guys are talking to mike though i
still approached him even though like he
had dropped something i still approached
him but like
people like in my relationship we have a
communication
like for example if i'm like looking at
something or someone
and he ends up looking at a woman you
know and he's like obviously
she's bad you know she's going on and
then like if i look at a guy and he's
he's looking fresh like whatever he's
wearing jeans and a nice shirt with some
nice shoes or like a suit and tie
he's looking good i will make the
comment and if he's passing by
just like my man does some people have
relationships like that
i've seen it where they might like
comment about the opposition i'll make a
comment he'll make a comment but it's a
mutual communication that
that person your boyfriend your
boyfriend lets you compliment men
other men stop the cat it's not a cat
well i don't think she means like this
is my best friend okay
so your boyfriend is okay with you
complimenting other men if i compliment
a man that obviously like i speak to him
and i'm like oh babe
he looks good and he's like you know
what yeah that's why he trusts the
loyalty company
i just want to finish my point and then
we're just going to go back to the
discussion at hand
but the thing is is that this uh podcast
is for men you know so we got to tell
guys
how reality really works you're clearly
an exception to the rule
most women don't approach men number one
number two
most men don't go to the nightclub to
get into i'm pretty sure i saw a study
where it said women make the first move
ninety percent of the time but it's not
through approaching them it's through
eye contact
let me know in the comments if you think
that's true or attention from women they
go to try to sleep with women the
difference is that women go to night
clubs to get attention from men
and a lot of the times what'll happen is
some girls go there to meet guys but
most girls don't and the thing is is
that you could say oh well you know i
can
you know i go to turn up with my girls
whatever if you really want to turn up
with your girls you would stay at home
and play the music there
no that's the scene for you to be
finding a girl at a club while she's
over here shaking her ass with her
friends or
she's drunk and she's lit and so now
she's really open is that like the place
that you want to meet your
future with like that's the difference
men go out to nightclub to get laid and
a man's sexual strategy get laid is
completely different than trying to find
a wife so
that's what i'm trying to say we tell
guys all the time nightclubs
like you can go there and talk to girls
it's fine but understand that a lot of
girls are there to take pictures for
their instagram
to you know show out to sit in the vip
for free get free liquor
and leave drinking your [ __ ] for free
that's the reality it's just that
girls aren't going to admit that no we
don't put you guys in there
hold on yeah you'll admit it here but
you ain't going to admit it at a
nightclub when someone listens to that
we're not here to [ __ ] any of you we're
here to just drink
point let's finish my them the last
thing i'm just gonna say is that like
on a balance of probabilities when a
girl goes out at night and she goes and
dresses herself a certain way all this
other stuff
a lot of times to get free attention
free drinks validation from the opposite
gender
and then go home with her girlfriend
sometimes they'll get laid sometimes
they won't it is what it is
but what you're saying with like guys
dressing up and looking good
from tick tock whatever pretty boys are
small minority
of most men they're a very small
minority of most men actually there's
studies that show it
women found 88 of men is unattractive on
tinder
88 the average guy is not attractive to
the average woman period
that's just the way it is you know what
i'm saying you're using anomalies saying
these pretty boys on tick tock go out to
get attention from girls
even if they do get attention from girls
girls don't approach them anyway so men
have to make the move
and i'll okay i understand what they're
saying
um i agree with them on the club thing i
think there's like different types of
like bars
and clubs um but in general like
especially a nightclub in miami
like come on you're obviously going
there to talk to the opposite gender
duh let me know in the comments if you
guys agree or you disagree
and do not forget to subscribe to the
channel as you guys know
20 000 subscribers is a big goal for me
so please please if you just
take a second subscribe to the channel